terminology and notation because as you
noticed outside right
we could have struggled what we're just
talking about the numbers we need some
more language to be able to say what's
going on here right and the three most
important piece of languages language
are these three words okay so here's
that first thing
now displacement tells you about where
something is it's a position where okay
but displacement is better than position
because for instance suppose you set out
to try and describe where is the ball at
any given time when it's in the air how
would you describe it well at the moment
like because we live in a 3d world it's
in 3d space so you have to provide a set
of coordinates for it but because we're
in 3d space there'd be an x-coordinate
and a y-coordinate and as in coordinate
and that's really difficult not to
mention the fact that we're only
interested in one of them right because
even though we live in three-dimensional
space it's only moving in one
dimensional space okay so therefore you
should say this question is in that
position we use an X to denote that okay
X being our variable of choice it can
get a bit confusing when you're talking
at things that we've up-and-down right
because when we graph this you're gonna
graph X and which axis will you use you
use the vertical axis right we're not
used to putting X on the vertical axis
we used to be Y there and that is
believed there's not a big source of
confusion but we're users X because well
Y is the next letter it's a bit weird
having a wire with no X so that's why we
just start with that
now our next idea afternoon you referred
to this outside is what what it is okay
now connected to velocity is the idea of
speed and they are not the same and we
really need to understand the difference
okay how to explain these speed and
velocity speed and velocity what I like
to think about is um you know picture
how many of you are learning to drive
you must have you good okay
so when you look at this phenomenal
you look at the other dial there and
you've got all of these numbers around
and then you have you know this thing
here which is just pointy there when
you're not moving okay it's at zero and
then you hold down the pedal and it
moves up and then you read off your
speed based on whatever it numbers point
down right now tell me what happens when
you shift into reverse and you press the
pedal down what happens to this it does
exactly the same thing that it does if
you weren't in Reverse right mainly it
goes up to like you know 60 if you're a
maniac to reverse at 60 okay just warn
me so I get out of the way okay this is
a speedometer it only tells you how fast
you're going right how fast you're going
let me put this in another color spoo
nominal speed is about how fast and it
doesn't care which way that direction
which way that speed is going okay it'll
be zero to 60 forwards or zero to 60
backwards or whatever okay our velocity
is different velocity is the same idea
of speed that it's about you know how
fast something is going but it takes
something additional into consideration
namely direction so the way I call
velocity is I call it speed with
direction now remember we are only
moving in one dimension right and that
might be up down or left right or
forwards backwards right but that's why
because you're in the moving in one
direction there are only two choices for
this right you're either going one way
or the other and so those correspond to
positive and negative so this direction
here that's positive
okay now in some ways because we're
making up you know all of this language
is how to describe this thing right we
can make positive and negative whatever
we like but some things tend to make
more sense than others for instance it
makes sense to come up positive right
because we're used to thinking you know
that way equals wasn't everything sounds
negative okay so as a convention you
will see positive means down how about
lift right for you guys
left right which makes more sense to be
positive and negative so we usually
think of a Cartesian plane right and
negatives off this way and positives of
this way right so therefore this will be
positive is right and it is okay it
doesn't have to be that way these are
conventions okay but if your situation
suits us for instance if I'm not
thinking about am if I'm not thinking
about someone throwing a ball up and
down maybe I want to think about for
instance someone dropping a ball off a
cliff and I want to think about that
distance maybe I will reverse this I can
do it however I like so long I defined
it okay okay
voici and speed you also need to think
about like how do we measure these
things okay this is the dominar right
What's it telling us at any given time
well in theory it's tell you what speed
you're doing at that moment you look at
it and it says 55 you're like right now
I'm moving a 55 close per hour right but
if you take your foot off the pedal then
it changes doesn't it okay so what
you're talking about there is what we
call and this is a cemetery really humid
it's either instantaneous as in an
instant of time that's the spin you've
got or what would be the opposite hmm
rather there's just looking at one
moment right you think about it of a
whole bunch of moments over say a whole
journey right so for instance it took me
oh I don't know about 12 minutes to get
to school and I knew
that it's about I think it's about six
kilometers okay so you could say that
that amount of um distance over time and
that wouldn't give you an instantaneous
speed of lhasa T would it want me to
give you an average okay so you can have
average speed and average velocity you
get an instantaneous speed and
instantaneous velocity right so these
kind of these categories overlap yeah
sure okay one last thing before we move
on to the next subway velocity right
when I release the ball okay
and it went upwards okay what does that
mean about the velocity it's positive
right now it's nice to come back down
it's negative by the time it ends right
so therefore I can think about when I'm
working at our average speed I told you
it was I drove six kilometers okay and
it took me that amount of time well
suppose like this ball right I drove and
I ended up where I started hmm what's
the total displacement how far away I'm
zero distance from where I started okay
so in that case even though I might be
driving for a while all I might be
throwing the ball pretty hard okay the
average speed would be or whatever you
calculate okay but the average velocity
well because I haven't gotten anywhere
really right over the whole journey
so therefore the average velocity be
zero
hmm that's funny does it make sense
though we'll come back to the ideas one
last thing going off here acceleration
well no I was naughty I forgot something
we call this X right we call this X so
therefore it stands to reason that if
you're thinking about velocity right
which is hard displacement is changing
over time what would you call that how
would you denote it DX lut good so your
rate of change idea and thinking about
how to read
just relate to quantities is go so here
either well here okay
we called speed Wasi right about how
fast this thing is changing well
acceleration does exactly the same thing
but it does it for speed right speed and
velocity so acceleration is about how
fast or if you like
at what rate it's just to help us kind
of how we talk at what rate how fast is
velocity changing now I've gotta warn
you right now acceleration is the
hardest part of motion to understand all
kinds of motion acceleration can be very
counter intuitive okay we're going to
unpack it as we go through it'll be
easier with examples I just want to give
you one quick warning never never ever
write the word or use the word
decelerate or deceleration okay we
talked about decelerating and
deceleration I guess if you had to
choose a synonym for this what would you
say slowing down good that makes sense
okay why is it such a bad idea to use
that word I'll tell you why when you
talk about slowing down right slowing
down is a speed word it's not a velocity
word okay it's about it's about this
right it's about zero to 60 and how
that's changing okay but acceleration is
really something about velocity we want
to take direction into account okay and
deceleration doesn't do it it just tells
you you know you're slowing down or
you're speeding up or that kind of thing
it doesn't tell you which direction
you're going okay so please PLEASE put
big red riding around it and make sure
you don't do that last bit of notation
if velocity is the change of
displacement in time DX Aditi but if I
want to know how DX 1 DT is changing I
differentiate again don't I now you can
always trust people from other fields of
study to muck things up for you so this
all looks mathematically beautiful right
but it's not just mathematicians who are
interested in displacement displacement
velocity and acceleration you know all
kinds of people were quite interested in
right and when you've got new kinds of
people who are interested in something
you get new ways of writing things okay
so thankfully for you everyone pretty
much agrees that we should call this X
okay but they're shuttin touch me who
who will remain unnamed who rather than
saying DX on DT they're like what's all
this D business I need to worry about
that what's differentiation I don't care
just give me formulas so I can work with
them they call it X dot not X - even
though that's what you're doing okay but
it's how extra changing will just make
the time X dot that's the way I read it
by the same token they talk about
acceleration not as displayed on because
I don't want to worry about the process
by which I get there they call it X
double dot okay
which kind of looks like a this looks
like a bad emotion calling anyway okay
so X DX mu T V squared X 1 DT squared I
think that's your safest bet unless they
introduced notation to you this should
be your default okay
but you need to recognize if you have
this guy's face off the course when they
talk about X dot and X double dot these
are what they mean okay they're talking
about velocity and acceleration